freedom is an alien concept for women
here they're not allowed to drive they
need male consent to travel or even just
to own a passport but for several years
women in Saudi Arabia have been
campaigning for equal rights filming
themselves behind the wheel and training
for football matches
they've even ventured into satire on
YouTube and it's having an effect
Saudi universities now have more female
than male students and over the next few
years the number of women in the
workforce is set to rise from 22 to 30
percent in the Saudi city of Jeddah the
nazma embroidery and tailoring center is
breaking new ground it employs more than
60 Saudi women that's unusual in this
extremely conservative Islamic Kingdom
it's managing director is Rana zoom I
herself a mother of three she pays her
staff well and provides them with a
minibus service and even daycare for
their children
a shy housewife should absolutely grab
this job opportunity even and in the
process learn how to make a more
confident impression in the beginning
when the customer Dana trusting us that
how I can deal as the man they are all a
woman some of the customer make the
order in minimum quantity because they
not trust that we can deliver but after
the first deal and the second deal and
the third deal now they depend on us in
all their quantity and big quantity we
keep it female because we want to
provide our women Muslim women's
environment they feel relief if they
want to work freely without wearing
hijab we feel more comfortable
the women are only wearing their veils
inside the factory today because of the
cameras in the beginning it was only I
want to work because I need the money
but they later discovered that the work
it's mean more than this the work we
mean the secure yourself feel your value
your rights in your community now the
target of the girl when she graduates
from the sundry school not only focused
what's meaning he will married she will
married no because she can't live
without me Fatima Ali is one of the
employees who is not married the most
important thing for me is to know that
I'm no longer financially dependent on
my parents that makes me feel so strong
all of a sudden I can just go out and do
things by myself things our society
doesn't think you're good for women
being with friends or being out and
about on my own in the past I was never
among people I was always at home today
I've made so many good friends a new
sense of freedom in a country that until
recently largely excluded women from
public life
you